[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact there's an old
country song that says if it wasn't for
bad luck I'd have no luck at all
well that might be how Dylan McWilliams
feels within a four year period Dylan
was bitten by a shark a bear and a
rattlesnake in April 2000 a teen he was
bitten by a shark while swimming fifty
yards off the coast of a beach in Hawaii
the scariest part was swimming back he
told local news adding that he was
hoping the shark wouldn't follow him
back for a second bite the leg wound
required several still stitches but
Dylan will be fine
in 2017 McWilliams received nine staples
in his scalp after a nearly 300 pound
bear invaded his Colorado campsite the
bear grabbed the back of my head and
started pulling me and I was fighting
back as best as I could
he told Hawaii news now it dropped me
and stomped on me a little bit until my
friend scared it away then there was the
rattlesnake bite which occurred about
three and a half years earlier in Utah
luckily McWilliams took only a small
amount of venom making him briefly ill
afterward not surprisingly the 20 year
old from Grand Junction says he spends a
lot of time outdoors
my parents are grateful I'm still alive
he said so the question is are some
people just unlucky stay with his
friends we're going to learn more on
this edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 72 97 I am
Doug Batchelor my name is John Ross and
pastor Doug as always before we take the
calls let's start with prayer dear
father in heaven we thank you for the
opportunity once again to be able to
open your word and study together when I
ask your blessing upon this program be
with the people who are listening
wherever they might be and guide us Lord
as we open up the scriptures here in the
studio lead us a clear understanding of
the word of the Bible in Jesus name Amen
amen
well pastor Doug that's an incredible
fact killed in the program let's talk
about bad luck here I mean just to be
bitten by a snake would be well that
doesn't usually happen that would bad
luck to be bitten by a bear well that's
pretty serious and to be bitten by a
shark
you wonder what next looking up looking
for lightning I don't know but that
would be three things that very
unexpected well any one of them most
people never experience to experience
all three yeah I mean so many people are
afraid of sharks and afraid of snakes
and maybe even afraid of bears but the
paper when they talked to McWilliams he
said I don't know if I'm either really
lucky or unlucky is thinking really
lucky cuz he survived all three with
Ceri I mean he had stitches but without
serious injury
but I wouldn't want to test my luck by
those things I've got a friend who
actually they say you can't be struck by
lightning twice well he was and he's
lucky he lived through it but whenever
we said lucky if you're a Christian it's
really a figure of speech because we
believe that there's a God who rules in
all the affairs of men and luck per se
is not what happens now that doesn't
mean that every time something happens
it's always God's will a plane may go
down and somebody will recklessly say
well I guess everybody on that plane was
displeasing God somehow and that's not
true you know sometimes a good perish
with the wicked we learned that from the
book of Job there's a passage where it
says in Ecclesiastes 9 verse 11 I
returned and I saw that under the Sun
the race does not go to the Swift nor
the battle to the strong nor the bread
to the wise no riches to men of
understanding nor favor to men of skill
what he's saying is these things don't
always happen that way but he adds time
and chance happens to them all sometimes
you know people are being affected by
certain sentences but God overrules in
those things now as far as being unlucky
the Bible says that if the children of
Israel turned away from him that certain
curses would follow them Amos paints a
very similar picture to what Dylan went
through it said it will be as though a
man fled from a lion and a bear met him
or as though he went into a house and
leaned his hand on the wall and the
serpent bit him and so you run from the
lion and he run into a bear and then he
turned you run of the house slammed the
door and leaned against the wall huffing
and puffing and the snake bites you and
it's like they say you can run but you
can't hide so um yeah I don't believe in
luck I think that there is a God who is
all powerful and he may allow certain
things and sometimes people are you know
caught up in times and circumstances of
war and God can work everything together
for good so we do believe in the
providential power of
but more importantly God has a plan and
a will for everybody's life and the main
thing is you want to know what is that
will we have a special offer we'd like
to make available it's free maybe you've
wondered how can I know God's will for
my life we have a book that's got about
12 steps with biblical guidelines so you
can help understand it'll help you
understand what is the will of God for
your life the book is called determining
the will of God and we'll be happy to
send this to anybody who calls an ass
again the books called determining the
will of God then I'm gonna call these
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven you can ask for the book
called determining the will of God will
be happy to send that to anybody who
calls and asks and if you have a Bible
question our phone line here to the
studio is 800 four six three seven two
nine seven the number once again is
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven if you have a Bible question
there's a good time to pick up your
phone and give us a call we have some
lines that are still open one more time
800 463 seven to 97 well pastor Doug I
think we're ready for our first write
today we have Kathleen listening in
Arizona Kathleen welcome to the program
hi thank you Pastor on faster good nice
said nice to see you
thank you taking my call I'm calling
about Revelation 1611 it's my
understanding that this is during one of
the seven last plagues that is poured
out and what I understand that once the
seven last plagues are poured out that
that you can't repent then that
probation is already closed why then in
1611 does it say that say if they did it
says they did not repent of their deeds
it will ask me the God of heaven and you
know right it's and pastor oz may weigh
in and all this also but it's my
understanding that yes probation has
closed it's basically saying that in
spite of the plagues there it's
confirming there beyond redeemable
qualities they don't repent they show no
remorse for their wickedness
and so it's basically justifying that
these plagues are falling on them yeah
you know when you look at the six or
seven last plagues that helps to reveal
the true nature of each person on the
one end you have the righteous when
these plagues have been fold falling
upon the earth they've been predicted
but they looking to God for deliverance
and they trusting in him whereas the
wicked their response is quite different
they rebelling against God even though
the note the plagues are coming because
of their sins their hearts are hard and
I think that's what's been emphasized in
verse 11 that despite all of this they
blaspheming God and they refuse to
acknowledge that you know they sent ya
even the Pharaoh of Egypt when the place
fell on ancient Egypt he showed some
temporary remorse the wicked in the last
days are not even showing temporary
murmurs so well we appreciate your
question I'm trying to think if we have
something that deals with the plagues in
Revelation we do have the book that
talks about the anything but secret
speaking of the second that's right that
would be if you want to learn more about
the second coming and events connected
with the second coming the number to
call is 883 five six seven four seven
you're gonna ask for the book called
anything but secret and I'll be happy to
send that out again 800 eight three five
six seven four seven and the book
anything but secret annex full of it we
have is let's say we have Molina and
Molina is listening where are you
listening from Molina alright welcome
justifying their yeah first Corinthians
chapter seven because I didn't think
anyone believed to justify someone
else's salvation what is that about yeah
well you're right nobody can save
someone else but the bible does say and
I think it's first Peter chapter three
that a believing wife can have a
converting influence on her unbelieving
husband
and when you have a believer in a family
that is praying for their children and
their spouse that may not be believers
there's a sanctifying influence where
God protects and provides because of the
prayers of the believer it's like when
lott was in sodom and he was going to be
destroyed abraham interceded with god
for a lot and God blessed and protected
lot because of the prayers and
intercession of Abraham so whenever
you've got a believer that saves in the
marriage with an unbeliever there's a
sanctifying influence why they're alive
it doesn't mean they save them just
means God's more likely to answer their
prayers and protect and bless alright
thank you
alright great question yeah and that by
the way is first Corinthians chapter 7
and there's several verses that talks
about that
maybe verse 10 on appreciate your call
Melanie next folder that we have is Dan
listening from New York Dan your own
Bible answers life thank you I believe
he did I the first thing he did was the
New Testament and then he began to work
on the Old Testament I know he was
working on it I imagining he did
complete it I don't know I'm pretty sure
the whole the whole Bible was translated
by Luther including Psalms and he may
have even done know that's the curious
thing to me what could he possibly in
Laurel oh well when Martin Luther went
to the University he learned Greek and
Hebrew he was very astute in languages
yeah before he ever wrote before he ever
protested against the beliefs of
Catholicism he had earned his doctorate
and among the things he studied was
languages yeah so he was a pretty good
theologian with the Greek in Hebrew and
in Latin I think he spoke matter of fact
when he gave his defence at Wittenberg
he gave it in German and then he gave it
again a second time in Latin so he was a
pretty good linguist I just looked it up
here online it's
the New Testament was translated by
Luther in 1522 and then in 1534 he
translated the Old Testament and the New
Testament and it quickly falls yeah yep
so yep it's on the internet it must be
true
no I've read that several times in
history books unfortunately yeah I do
know that he said so and you know it's
very troubling because he says so many
wonderful things about Christ and
Christianity and then you read some of
the things he said about the Jews it is
your right and it's some people have
wondered if the later in his life when
he wrote those things they're wondering
if there was some form of dementia that
was affecting him because it seems so
out of character for the earlier work in
his life but no I I know exactly what
you're saying you read the beautiful
things he says about the gospel and
grace and love and forgiveness and and
then you read some of his letters about
the Jews in particular it's kind of
shocking but hey we appreciate your
question and we do have a book on the
Bible it talks about the ultimate
resource we'll send you a free copy the
number to call is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and you
can ask for the book called the ultimate
resource all about the Bible and the
different translations again that number
is 885 six seven four seven next caller
that we have is Alexandra listening from
Chicago Alexandra welcome to the program
hi thank you thank you for calling so my
question is kind of personal when I was
around I I guess I'll just say me 18 I
feel like I was saved and my life became
different and wonderful and I was so
full of joy and happiness and you later
down one if you like it's almost like
that was stripped away from me and I
feel like now I question was I ever
saved and I remember LLY a lot of her
book stated that you should never
question whether you were saved or not
you should believe in with everything
you have that you were saying to me um
so I wonder how they get that feeling
back again right I'm sorry go ahead
my question is can God sometimes take
that away and put you through some kind
of a test well the answer to that is yes
dude it's not that he's taking away your
joy but sometimes God will test our
faith and you know there are times when
the Lord is speaking loudly and we sense
his presence and his joy there are times
when trials come and even Jesus who was
perfect went through a trial where it
seemed his father was separated from him
while his father was separated from them
for our sake so we all but don't
question you know if you have taken up
God's promise if he says you know if you
come to me I am faithful and just to
cleanse you from all your sins I will
forgive your sins
when you repent of them you may not feel
anything
but you must believe it and he says I
will never leave you or forsake you and
all that come to me I will in no wise
cast out sometimes you can find a
renewal in that joy pastor Ross and I
were talking to one of the members of
our church this week and and he's
probably nearly 80 years old he said
he's has been praying for the joy he
felt when he first accept Christ and the
Lord gave it back to him and he just he
looked like it - he was just beaming and
so you know sometimes it's seeking after
the Lord and rediscovering that first
love that's what Jesus said in Ephesians
I'm sorry in Revelation chapter 2 this
is yeah absolutely and you know there is
a good book that talks about that it's
called justification assurance and we'll
send you a free copy of my book on
justification and assurance if you just
call the resource line number e coli's
883 five six seven four seven after the
book called assurance justification made
simple I think is what is that right you
know what better than me and I wrote it
and the number again is 883 five six
seven four seven and asked for the book
on salvation called assurance
justification made simple next one of
the B heavies Dave listening from
Wisconsin Dave welcome to the program of
greetings greetings thank you for
calling my question is how I know you
shouldn't base your theology at any one
text and this only appears once in
scripture but first Corinthians 15:29
talks about baptism for the dead or of
the dead okay are you wondering if what
if it means that we should be baptized
in behalf of the dead well I know some
different theologies I am trying to sort
things out yeah now what first were you
saying first Corinthians 15 25 29
thought you said 59 I was wondering
about that but this is one of those
cases where putting the punctuation in
the wrong place gives it an entirely
different meaning the way this verse
ought to read now keep in mind I believe
the Bible is inspired but all the
punctuation was added by English
translators whenever you go from one
language to another there is no
punctuation in the original Greek so the
the King James translators and others
have had to say well where do we put the
commas here because it changes the
meaning of everything so let me read the
verse the way it appears and then I'll
tell you the way that some scholars have
moved the commas to make more sense out
of it it says otherwise what will they
do who are baptized for the dead if the
dead do not rise at all why then are
they baptized for the dead and why do we
stand in jeopardy every hour okay now
this is the way I believe it should be
translated otherwise what what will they
do who are baptized , for the Dead , if
the dead rise not at all
, why then are they baptized , for the
dead question mark he's not saying being
baptized for the dead he's saying those
who are baptized if the dead don't rise
why be baptized are you doing it for the
dead he's asking rhetorically
you see what I'm saying so the whole
discussion first Corinthians 15 is there
doubting the resurrection Paul is saying
what will they do who are baptized well
what good is it to be baptized , for the
dead if the dead rise not at all
, why then are they baptized for the
dead so he's saying if you're just gonna
get baptized and die what good is
baptism you don't have eternal life
there's no resurrection he's not
suggesting people get baptized for the
dead because first of all then you look
at the other verses the Bible says it's
appointed unto man once to die and after
this the judgment
when a person's dead the living cannot
then pray them into heaven you can't
burn candles he can't pay money the
Bible says the righteousness of the
righteous will be on him and I forget
the verse that Ezekiel 18 pastor ross
the wickedness of the wicked will be
upon him a man will save neither son nor
daughter now every man is delivered by
his own righteousness and their own
faith in Christ so the idea that the
living somehow are gonna intercede and
change the destiny of the dead flies in
the faith face of everything else in the
Bible thank you very much
so okay and hopefully that helps you
know I had a write a little it's too
short for a book but I got to write
something more on that because it's a
great question
the verse you referring to second
chronicles chapter 6 verse 23 talks
about each person being justified by
their own faith oh thank you very much
our next caller that we have is another
caller listening and Wisconsin we have
ken who is listening ken welcome to the
program hi good evening pastor our
evening yes I have a question on first
Corinthians chapter 9 verses 19 through
23 what does that mean like Paul what is
he saying like I have a lot of things
that I'm kind of wondering all right let
me read it verse 19 through roughly 23
okay
he says for though I am free from all
man I've made myself a servant to all
that I might win the more and to the
Jews I became as a Jew that I might win
the Jews and to those who are under the
law as under the law that I might win
though
under the law to those who are without
laws without law but not being without
law towards God but under the law
towards Christ that I might win those
who are without law to the week I became
weak that I might win the week I've
become all things to all men that I
might by all means save some
and now this I do for the Gospels sake
that I might be a partaker of it Paul is
basically saying I relate to people as
much as possible to reach them without
sacrificing principle and then he gives
an example for the Jews who are still
under the ceremonial laws Paul said I
went to Jerusalem he can read in the
book of Acts I shaved my head I took a
vow I went to the temple I went through
one of the ceremonial laws to try to
relate to the Jews so I could reach the
Jews because if they think that I had
cast off the laws of Moses it's harder
to reach them so he said for their sake
I did that to reach them then when he
was with the Gentiles he said I was as
one without the law meaning without the
ceremony law that I might reach those
who are without the law being the
Gentiles he clearly specifies halfway
through verse 20 not being without law
towards God mean he says I'm not
breaking the moral law but he said you
know the ceremonial laws he he would try
and reach those he didn't practice
circumcision he didn't believe in
keeping the feast days and the Jews said
you weren't supposed to eat with a Jew
with a Jew with an a Gentile and Paul
said why I disregarded all those laws
that I might reach the Gentiles so Paul
is saying as far as possible be
respectful of people's customs relate to
people as much as you can without violin
and a principle so you can reach them
and also on the 1st Corinthians 8
chapter 9 what is he saying again like
beware lest somehow this Liberty of
yours become a stumbling-block to those
who are weak
yea Paul is saying and he also says in
Romans 14 he said you know don't do
anything that's gonna make your brother
stumble and but basically what Paul is
saying is let me give you the background
there was a dispute in the early church
and you can read about it I forget where
it is in Corinthians where he says
he whatever sold in the market not
asking questions for conscience sake
many of the very zealous religious Jews
would not even eat meat clean meats
we're talking about they wouldn't even a
clean meat that was bought in a Gentile
marketplace for fear that it had been
offered to a pagan God before they
butchered it because I verse yeah
first Corinthians 10:25 I want to read
real quick it says eat what every soul
in the meat market asking no questions
for conscience sake now the question you
weren't supposed to ask was you're not
supposed to say I don't care whether
this is a pig or a goat or a lamb the
question you weren't supposed to ask was
is this offered to a pagan god so some
people have had a very sensitive
conscience and Paul is saying look you
know you don't want to go if you're with
a Jew who is very sensitive about buying
meat in the marketplace a Gentile
marketplace because it could have been
sacrificed to a pagan God don't do it in
front of them cuz it's gonna bother them
but you are free you realize the idol is
nothing and that's I'm quoting Paul they
it can't do anything how they have no
power over it it doesn't change the
essence of what you're buying and he
said it doesn't bother me but he said if
it bothers someone else I won't do
anything like that in front of my
brother because it'll make him stumble
so that's the freedom that Paul is
talking about he says don't let your
Liberty knowing that the idols aren't
anything and that you have Liberty to
buy this food in the marketplace that
you know the pagans may be offering it
to their gods an example is let me give
you a modern example I like Chinese food
I like Thai food frequently I'll go to a
Chinese or a Thai restaurant they got a
little statue of Buddha there with
incense burning now they may be
Buddhists I don't feel guilty eating
there because there's a statue of Buddha
in the restaurant it doesn't bother me I
don't worship Buddha I pray that God
will bless my food and I pray to Jesus
before I eat I maybe have gone to the
restaurant with somebody who said oh we
can't eat here look the idol I'll say ok
let's go somewhere else
for for their sake their conscience is
sensitive I'll do something different
that's the kind of thing Paul is talking
about so hopefully that makes sense hey
you know we're gonna we're gonna bump
into a break here in just a moment did
that help a little bit yes yes
right then we do have a book called why
the Old Covenant failed and I think
it'll deal with this idea especially
something Paul's dealing with here in
Corinthians to receive the book all you
have to do is call our resource phone
line that's eight hundred eight thirty
five six seven four seven you can ask
for the book called why the Old Covenant
failed our next call at the behalf is
Dennis listening in Vacaville Dennis
welcome to the program yes I know
in Daniel seventy weeks are determined
upon thy people and then of course after
the crucifixion the Romans scattered the
Jews is there a prophecy of that comes
later in time of the Jews coming back
like after the Holocaust with Hitler is
there a prophecy of them coming back in
1948 or any other time like that or are
there no prophecy for that well I'll
tell you what you can hear the music
we're going to go into a break your
question and the answer your question is
going to be first thing on the other
side of this break you take a moment
friends to identify our station for a
number of our affiliates around the
country in the world but don't go
anywhere we're coming back with more
Bible questions and we do have lines
open 804 six three seven two nine seven
I stand by we'll get to your call
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
throughout recorded history tales of
ghosts and spirits can be found in
folklore in nearly every country and
culture Egyptians built pyramids to help
guide the spirits of their leaders Rome
sanctioned holidays to honor and appease
the spirits of their dead even the Bible
tells of a king that used a witch to
contact the spirit of a deceased prophet
today ancient folklore of spirits and
apparitions have gone from mere
superstitions to mainstream
entertainment and reality scientific
organisations investigate stories of
hauntings and sightings trying to prove
once and for all the existence of ghosts
even with all the newfound technology
and centuries of stories all over the
world there is still no clear-cut answer
so how do we know what's true why do
these stories persist does it even
matter
we invite you to look inside and find
out for yourself visit death truth calm
for life changing Christian resources
this @af bookstore calm every bible
question you have answered moves you one
step closer to the fullness of god's
will for your life
so what are you waiting for get the
answers you need for a fuller richer
more confident life you're listening to
Bible answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 smite come
back after they were conquered and
scattered by the Romans is that right
Dennis that's my main question yeah is
there anything that would correlate to
1948 and and the passion that I guess
England in the u.s. had for allowing the
Jews because of Hitler's Holocaust
to allow them sort of crowd back into
Palestine and I'm wondering is there a
prophecy for that yeah well tell you
what there is a prophecy that says in
Luke chapter 21 verse 24 speaking of the
fall of Jerusalem it said o Jerusalem
will be trodden down by the Gentiles
until the times of the Gentiles are
fulfilled and so anyone who's a Gentile
is technically or anyone who is not a
Jew as a Gentile and you cannot deny how
remarkable it was that three times
throughout history the Jewish nation has
been displaced from their property once
in the days of Jacob when they went down
to Egypt then they were carried away by
the Babylonians and they came back and
then for 1,900 years after the Roman
dispersion they got their land back and
less than a week ago pastor and I were a
pastor Ross and I were in the Holy Land
which is why we sound fuzzy right now
it's we feel like we've been up all
night with our wives and just had an
amazing tour there and did some speaking
ran into people a number of people who
watched the amazing facts programs met
one lady who was baptized in the Middle
East in Israel from listening to our
programs so it was just a very enriching
time and the Bible comes alive when you
go over there you can just see what a
miracle it is that here Israel is they
spend more on security than any other
nation in the world because they're
surrounded on all sides by nations that
land maybe not currently but at one time
or another have been hostile and yet
they are continuing to grow and thrive
and becoming an international center for
technology and innovation so it's just
uncanny that after being this place for
1,900 years you would retain your
culture your language your your a
history and then get your land back just
incredible so some have looked at that
prophecy and then you mentioned the
prophecy in Revelation
yeah Revelation chapter 11 talks about
not measuring the courtyard for it is
given to the Gentiles
they'll tread under foot for 42
in the bible courtyard represents the
earth and some have connected that to
the jews being expelled from jerusalem
from their land but then finally been
returning being restored to the land
yo pastor day you didn't mention
something interesting about the jewish
people we were over there visiting and
of course we saw some wonderful sights
but it's rather remarkable that you have
a group of people that like you said
were dispersed to the four corners of
the earth and they were speaking other
languages in the different places where
they end up ended up they were
surrounded by totally different cultures
and yet they kept their language their
identity their culture and kind of came
back that doesn't typically happen when
nations get conquered and dispersed no
they just they sort of get absorbed yeah
and yeah disappear they evaporate
thank you very much death oh we have a
book that you'll enjoy it's called
spiritual israel we'll send you a free
copy that if you call in the number to
call is eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven you can ask for the
book called spiritual israel I'll be
happy to send it to anyone who calls and
asks Abdul is listening from Minnesota
Abdul welcome to the program hello how
are you doing good thank you for calling
thank you for taking this call I had a
moment I wanted to ask a question from
the pastor I hope he could get some time
and answer that or put some magic put
some light on the last few seconds
before Lord this man Caleb the spirit
and moments after and also in light and
what happened also in heaven just just
the pastor could put some light in that
so when Jesus was on the cross and he
ultimately said it is finished father
into your hands I commend my spirit
you're wanting to know what was
happening on earth and in heaven when
that happened yes I want to definitely
certainly want to know that because I
mean I am a born and I was a Muslim I
become Christian and I do believe it but
I'd like to know from a biblical
perspective and
for my butt to know what actually took
place and more in details because so far
I haven't found more all right let me
share with you what the what I believe
and it might surprise you how simple it
is the Bible says Christ died for our
sins and I think there's another verse
it says as the scripture says he died
three days later he rose when Lazarus
died and this is John chapter 11 jesus
said our friend Lazarus is asleep and I
go that I might wake him some people
have believed that when Jesus died he
didn't really die on the cross that he
kind of transmigrated to heaven or he
went to hell and preach to people and
give him a second chance and they've got
a number of theories about what happened
but I'm of the group that believes that
Jesus did take our penalty in the
penalty for sin is death that he died
and during that time he wasn't going
anywhere it's like saying you know where
was Jesus when he was in the womb you
get the same kind of issue when Jesus
when Mary conceived and Jesus was being
carried around as an embryo and a baby
inside Mary you know did he have all his
divine mental properties that did he
come out uh during if when he was born
did he come out uh during profound
truths no he was a baby God the Son
Jesus laid aside his divinity when he
came to our earth he did not take that
up again until after his three days and
three nights in the tomb so he died like
men died and he rose Sunday morning he
doesn't say he was nowhere in the bible
does it say he was gallivanting around
heaven or hell doing other things while
he was dead okay alright thank you so
much for taking the call I appreciate
this is a yeah yeah let me tell you what
let's send you a free book we've got a
study guide actually that has all the
scripture that you're looking for and
it's called are the dead really dead and
we'll send you a free copy and I'm to
Coley's eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven you're gonna just
ask for that study guide
simply called are the dead really dead
over happy to send that to you Abdul or
anyone who calls and asks next caller
that we have is Roger listening Colorado
Roger welcome to the program thank you
for having me pastor Doug I have an
interesting question where did the 24
elders come from I could not find that
in the Bible well that's a great
question we have to do a little bit of
speculation you read in the book of Job
chapter 1 where it says there was a day
when the sons of God came to present
themselves before the Lord and Satan
came also some kind of a heavenly
meeting Satan comes ostensibly to
represent the earth and some theologians
have said well perhaps the sons of God
are the same 24 elders that are leaders
or rulers of unfallen world's some have
thought that they were you know the
leaders of angels some have argued the
Bible says that when Jesus rose from the
dead in Matthew chapter 28 that ours at
27 many of the Dead resurrected around
Jerusalem assemble said well maybe it's
some of these patriarchs and kings and
prophets that were raised with Jesus at
his resurrection that around his throne
the Bible doesn't say I am inclined to
think that those elders around the
throne are the representatives of
unfallen worlds or quadrants of the
galaxy there's some form of leadership
God uses the number 12 yo on earth as
his leadership twelve tribes twelve
apostles he may use the same number in
heaven to divide up his leadership and
we believe there are unfallen worlds
that have not sinned this is the only
world that sinned and rebelled according
to the Bible so that's yeah well that's
one theory and now I have a book that
talks about that a little bit and it's
called who are the sons of God because
it talks about the sons of God and Jobe
talks about these sons of God in Genesis
6 and I'll send you a free copy of it
it's a what we call a mini book if you'd
like to copy that yes I would okay the
number to call is 808
three five six seven four seven you can
answer the book on the 24 elders number
again is 808 three five six seven four
seven we'll be happy to send that to you
who are the sons of God who are the sons
of God that's right
talking a little bit about the 24 elders
in there who are the sons of God is the
name of the book that you need asked for
next corner that we have is Kesser
listening in massachusetts chants are
welcome to the program how are you hi
how are you thank you and your question
yeah I think yeah
my question was mustn't Kalani's are
speaking in tongues
I was wondering of course okay I'm a
Christian but sometimes I'm defeated
because maybe I don't speak in tongues
or ask myself does it mean I'm not a
Christian or a lot now you're a church
you see people speaking in tongues in
your church not even my church but the
artichokia yeah you know this is one of
the most misunderstood subjects and let
me just tell you you want to be like
Jesus right I'm sorry a Christian is a
follower of Christ you want to be like
Christ yeah yeah yeah okay where in the
Bible do you see Jesus speaking in
tongues speaking times actually
yeah the the it's a misunderstood
subject Jesus told the Apostles you will
speak with other tongues in mark chapter
16 because they were all Jews they spoke
Aramaic he wanted to give them the
ability to speak in a language they did
not formally know our study on the day
of Pentecost he poured out his spirit he
gave them the ability to speak in the
languages of the visiting Jews so Peter
and the Apostles and those in the upper
room were given these tongues of fire
because they were given the supernatural
ability to speak in other languages if
right now I should start speaking in
Portuguese that would be a gift to the
spirit because I've never studied
Portuguese but if the Lord wanted to
give me that gift to speak
Brazilians that are listening that would
be a gift of the tongues so this is what
the gift of tongues was for there are
three examples of tongues in the book of
Acts there's only three in the whole
Bible Acts chapter 2 Acts chapter 10 in
Acts chapter 19 in all three examples
there are multiple language groups
represented the believers are given the
ability to speak and understand in other
languages so and that's what it's
talking about in 1st Corinthians chapter
14 so I have a book I've written on that
I'll send you a free copy and all you've
got is called understanding tongues all
you've got to do is ask number to call
is 808 three five six seven four seven
after the book called understanding
tongues or Baptists send that to anybody
who calls and asks we've got Scott to
his listening in California Scott
welcome to the program hey how are you
guys great thank you for calling I'm
calling it's kind of a complicated
discussion but when you guys get up in
the morning you put on the mind of
Christ and the whole armour of God and
do you as far as I'm divorced and I'm
thinking of the sanctuary it's kind of a
two-part question you guys do that put
on your armor and the mind of Christ and
go through a regiment kind of like a
military instructor or is it not
supposed to be so strict well I can't
that's a good question and I can't speak
for pastor Ross but I I think in
Ephesians six when Paul talks about
putting on the armor he's speaking in
analogous language he's not saying that
we need to every morning in a kind of
imaginary or even in our mind dawn the
armor yeah I think he's talking about
let's make sure that we embrace the
truth of Christ it's the belt of truth
and the breastplate of righteousness and
the helmet of salvation and I've written
a book on that I'll send you a copy but
personally for me when I pray in the
morning I want to pray for the Holy
Spirit if you have the holy
it gives you the mind of Christ so one
of the simplest prayers I pray is that I
can have the Spirit of God the spirit of
Christ if you've got the Spirit of
Christ that's the mind of Christ and
then I read his word which is the word
of Christ and in reading his word one of
the one of the elements of the armor of
God is and even in the sanctuary you've
got that bread you got the light thy
word is a lamp unto my feet the bread is
man doesn't live by bread alone but by
every word so as you study the word in
the morning and you pray for God's
Spirit and you commune with the Lord you
are doing those things in effect so do
you have the spirit of comportment not
always but but you know I unlike anyone
else I sometimes I pray in the morning
and I still feel grumpy but I then I
Drive very a little longer but I
understand from reading that the Spirit
of content that comes along with
godliness godliness with contentment is
great gain first yeah there that's true
you know the the more content we are
with a simple Christian life discontent
often comes because you want something
you don't have or you have expectations
that a Christian shouldn't have
that usually leads to that you know we
also have to remember the Bible tells us
that we need to walk by faith not by
sight so there are times where we might
feel close to the Lord and we'll have
peace and contentment but there are
other times when we might not feel that
way doesn't mean that God's attitude to
us has changed but to walk by faith
means we claim the promises of His Word
irrespective of how he might feel I
think that's putting on the armor of God
it's something we do by faith claiming
the promises of his word not looking to
our own feelings but trusting in his
word hey thank you very much you know we
do have a book on the armor of God and
we'll be happy to send you a free copy
of that number to call he's eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven just asked for the book called the
armor of God and again we'll be happy to
send it to anyone who calls and asks
we've got Michael listening in Canada
Michael welcome to the pro
good day pastor dozen and pastor Roth
how are you guys tonight
very good thank you for calling in your
question my question is to do with
adultery my uncle I won't name any names
but you told me that if if you remarry
and your ex spouse isn't passed away
that you're committing adultery and that
you're not going to go to heaven is that
true or false well if you remarry
without biblical grounds the Bible tells
us that that is a sin but the idea that
it is the unpardonable sin
the bible does not teach because if that
was the case then abraham wouldn't make
it because he divorced hagar and david
would not make it because he married
bathsheba under very dubious
circumstances so the idea that it is a
sin there are things that are qualify as
a sin marrying or divorcing without
biblical grounds Jesus speaks against to
say that you can't go to heaven then
that there's no repentance so there's no
hope I think we got to be careful about
saying things like that it's you know if
whenever you send anything you need to
repent of that sin now sometimes people
divorce and remarry and they don't have
biblical grounds and they have children
and and then they get converted they
come to Christ and they think well what
do I do now divorce my wife and abandon
my my present children well no as I
heard one pastor say you cannot
unscramble scrambled eggs so you just
you know God meets us where we're at and
you've got to go from there
after David sinned with Bathsheba he was
punished for his sin punished severely
but God never told him now I want you to
dump Bathsheba he had already killed her
husband so she remained his wife for the
rest of David's life okay so hopefully
that helps yeah we have a book whatever
you send your free copy oh you left to
do is call the number I'll tell you in
just a minute
ask for the book called marriage divorce
and remarriage the number to call is
eight hundred eight thirty five six
seven four seven I'm gonna say it again
eight 200t three five six seven four
seven as for the book marriage divorce
remarriage we'll be happy to send it to
anyone who calls and asks we've got
Angela listening from Orlando Angela
welcome to the program hi from Florida
first of all I just wanted to say thank
you thank you guys I got sick last year
very sick I had to give up my job and
and I listened to amazing facts and I
couldn't go to church and and that
really saved me and I wanted to thank
you that I you know thank God that the
blessing of amazing facts well praise
the Lord thank you for that and that's
why we do it and my mom she lets us you
pastor Doug and she wants to know how do
you you read everything off the one
paper you open up the Bible and she says
man he remembers lots of stuff and he's
got it on one piece of paper
well in my you know when I preach what I
do is I put a piece of sticky
double-sided tape on the inside vinyl
the very open into the Bible and because
we're doing this on TV
it takes precious time to turn I will
print out on my page all the scriptures
I'm going to read and so I have I have
notes but a lot of what I do is
extemporaneous or I've kind of you know
I know the stories I know the I know
where I'm going in my message so no I
don't have a photographic memory I've
got the scriptures written on that piece
of paper what she thinks you guys should
he goes he must be doing shorthand and I
said well maybe mom I don't know well it
is it's not shorthand but I I sometimes
will put a few verses and I know the
rest of the verse in my head so I just
need a few references to help me
remember well my question was I was
listening to moody radio and I have a
friend she's who assists a moody radio a
lot and I just listened to it once in a
while and the other day they were
talking about how Jesus is coming before
Jesus comes back again he's going to
come back as healing people and he's
going to come back saving people that
there's gonna be lots of life saved when
he comes
and this was from booty radio and I was
like I wanted to know where did they get
that from because I never heard of that
before and I was kind of like start a
little bit I said where's that from
and um maybe you could enlighten me a
little bit yeah I my guess is no moody
radio has some you know wonderful
programs and they'll even just read the
Bible on there sometimes and they have
music is usually pretty good but some of
the teachers believe that Christ comes
back after seven years of tribulation
and the Millennium is here on earth and
that he's going around then doing
healing and things we don't believe that
we believe that when Christ comes again
we are caught up to meet him in the air
he said I go to prepare a place for you
when I come again I'll take you to the
places I prepared so we believe that
before the Millenium we are going up we
live and reign with him for a thousand
years in his kingdom we do not believe
that the righteous are reigning over the
wicked for a thousand years we don't see
that supported in the Bible who would
want to do that I mean what righteous a
person who has an eternal body wants to
reign over a world full of wicked people
that have mortal bodies it just it's a
really strange picture so at the end of
the 1,000 years we come down the wicked
are judged destroyed and God makes a new
heaven new earth the New Jerusalem
settles into the valley that God has
prepared now we have a study on the
Millennium that gives you that sequence
and we will send you a free copy if you
ask the study guide is called a thousand
years of peace and just call and ask for
that the number is 883 five six seven
four seven I asked for the study guide
called a thousand years of peace it's
all about all Revelation chapter 20 that
1000 year period we'll be able to send
that to anyone who calls and asks our
next holy is Becky listening from
Michigan Becky welcome to the program
yeah
I personally am baptized last month oh
you just you say you just got baptized
last month please Lord
I don't know questions at the biblical
standpoint how do I other concerns Jeff
how do you overcome stress and fear and
fear you know I'm writing a book right
now I was working on today called
worrying about stuff and it's talking
about stress and fear and I give about
50 different points in there I probably
can't cover them all right now one thing
is don't watch the evening news is often
full of rewards and things let let me
just give you a couple thoughts real
quick Becky you agree that every life
has problems right yes if you only can
be happy when there are no problems
you'll never be happy so you need to
learn to be happy in spite of their
being problems in life which means what
you do is you acknowledge that there are
problems you present those to the Lord
and pray for wisdom you do what you can
humanly do to solve the problems
sometimes you might even write them out
and say you know here are the issues
here are the things that worry me spread
it before the Lord and say Lord give me
wisdom to solve these problems if
they're things I can't solve help me to
accept it and give me peace the Bible
says cast your cares upon the Lord
because he cares for you Jethro told
Moses when Moses was trying to carry all
the burdens of Israel he said the thing
you're doing is too much for you it's
gonna crush you and you know if you
carry all those sorrows yourself you
can't do that and so you God wants you
to have joy you gotta cast your cares
upon him even Jesus through his life
when he knew he was going to the cross
he could still tell the disciples I'm
giving you joy and peace that you can't
comprehend so if Jesus could be happy
knowing what was in his future then we
can all be happy just yeah you got to
cast it on the Lord do what you can to
take care of your problems then set on
the side make an appointment every day
and sit for this half an hour I'm gonna
worry and try and troubleshoot pray that
God will give you wisdom and then leave
that half an hour alone and go and move
on with your life and enjoy yourself all
right keep an eye on amazing facts when
our book comes out called worrying about
stuff you'll I think you'll find the
blessing in it
is that really what I think it is did we
run out of time already the pigs I
wasn't paying attention to our engineer
but I know what that means we got 10
seconds to say goodbye how am I gonna do
that
hey friends thank you so much for tuning
in you can keep listening on amazing
facts are G and while you're at it if
you click the button that says donate
you'll make it possible to keep
listening and for others to hear
god bless til we talk next week thank
you for listening to today's broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before tune in next time for
more Bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible questions
you were looking through my watch and I
found a way you can save big on your
taxes now that you are 7 did I have to
sold you commit charitable donations to
amazing facts and I are a charitable
rollover is a win-win for you and the
Lord's work first it satisfies your
minimum distribution it reduces your
taxable income it is not subject to the
50% deduction limit and your gift helps
amazing facts bring people to Jesus call
amazing facts today to see how we can
help you get the most out of your IRA
the number to dial is 800 436 to 695 or
visit my legacy dot amazing facts org
did you know that Noah was present at
the birth of Abraham okay maybe he
wasn't in the room
but he was alive and probably telling
stories about his floating zoo from the
creation of the world to the last day
events of Revelation Bible history calm
is a free resource where you can explore
major Bible events and characters
enhance your knowledge of the Bible and
draw closer to God's Word
go deeper visit Bible History com
amazing facts through your faithful
support has had a major impact on some
of the largest non-christian locations
in the world
f co global opened up Center of
evangelism schools in India the Ukraine
the United Kingdom and even in the
Philippines it's people on the ground in
the church on the door in the hope doing
Bible studies witnessing to people
winning them to Jesus leading them to
baptism in England in India and Africa
or anywhere around the world but you're
seeing change on a personal level take
place you know every week we hear the
most incredible stories from all over
the globe of lives that are being
changed and hearts that are being
transformed by the power of the word and
none of it could happen without the
blessing of God and our partnership your
teamwork with this ministry god bless
you
written by the hand of God and spoken
with his voice
some words will never fade
yet pastor Doug bachelors twelve part
sermon series on the Ten Commandments by
calling 805 three eight seven 275 or
visit AF bookstore comm if you'd like to
enhance your study of God's Word
visit our website at WWF ag0 RG and sign
up for our free Bible study course and
make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore com